the Joe Rogan experience yeah that is
something that politicians do they
utilize this moment to try to use it to
leverage their own causes their own pet
causes things that they think are also
important there are a group of people
that did that with the invasion of Iraq
when 9/11 came along they said look Iraq
is harboring al-qaeda terrorists they
probably are getting weapons into the
hands and people like oh okay there was
a whole story that was woven up and that
was a way of essentially crippling the
fourth largest army in the world which
was Iraq and making our allies Gerry
here the Bill Hicks bit he goes they
said Bill Iraq is the fourth largest
army he goes yeah but after the first
three there's a real big drop-off he's
like the fifth largest is a Salvation
Army it's so true yeah yeah a whole
great bit about the size of armies well
we've been in we were in Afghanistan for
how long was it guys because he goes hey
Bill they say Bill it's a war when
there's two armies fighting yeah he goes
Bill Iraq is a fourth largest army in
the world doesn't mean we won't stay
there he had some great bits man some
great points [ __ ] yeah not outside the
box that's what I'm always amazed at is
how these things can carry on like if
you did somebody did a really cool funny
thing about how every general in the
Iraq in the Afghanistan theater every
single every single year would say we
are at a turning point where the Taliban
will be under our control every every
every time they would make a case for
the Iraq war more money I'm sorry for
the Afghan Afghan war more money more
logistics all those things that required
more troops the generals would say we
are it was always the same wording we're
at a turning point and we are gonna we
just need a little more and that's well
that's what they have to say yeah but
what's interesting is if they really did
accomplish that they'd actually cut off
the honeypot
have the money comes Ryan that's that's
that's the darkest conspiracy ever that
war is prolonged in order to prop up the
military-industrial complex
and what's really crazy about the
military-industrial complex is when
there was Eisenhower talking about it on
TV which was really terrifying that was
when the first people were introduced to
this concept but Trump was talking about
recently
you know Trump is doing this thing he's
like well you know this is a
military-industrial complex and these
guys want to go to war like he's just
saying it's pretty casually like hey man
who are you talking about yeah like who
are these [ __ ] there's a lot of money
in it and and not only that there are
other people nongovernmental
organizations to that get rated by their
burn rate so we're gonna build a dam
here well we don't need a dam here but
we're gonna build it anyway because
we're a lot of that money there's a lot
of that goes on so it's that's why with
conspiracy theories I'm Way more apt to
believe that the government is is way
more incompetent that it is competent I
don't it's just a massive bloated
bureaucracy that doesn't run well I
don't know no guys I know there's a
group of people controlling everything
the [ __ ] out of here there's a little
bit of that there's definitely a lot of
incompetence but there's also a lot of
collusion there's also a lot of people
doing things specifically because they
know it's profitable to make money yes
[Applause]